[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sock and
super excited to be talking about
influencing the global brain we have
sterling Cooley joining us on the show
hello brother
hey how's it going man good to see ya
super excited for the show so it's
finally happening totally yeah we
greatly appreciate all of the love that
you've been passing along to simulation
so many of our friends have been on the
show yeah sharing those shows now it's
time to feature you it's excited so
pumped for those that don't know
Sterling's background sir and Chloe is a
thought leader and pioneer in the use of
ultrasound to modulate neural activity
in the human brain and nervous system he
is a contributor to the transfer of
Technology quarterly report for vagus
nerve sector he also runs the fastest
growing community on vagus nerve
stimulation and repair his other
interests are in bringing a neuro
scientific understanding to how the
modern corporation operates to increase
well-being productivity and human
thriving within the organization and you
can find the links in the bio below two
sterling Cooley comm as well as the
Facebook group that's facebook.com for
slash groups for slash the vagus nerve
so do check that out join that group
awesome sterling let's start things off
with one of our favorite questions to
ask our guest what are your thoughts on
the direction of our world that's a good
question
I think a lot of people are a little bit
more pessimistic than they need to be I
think we have to have a framing of
optimism because that's the only way we
can find really good solutions and we
have to be curious enough to be
receptive for the answers so I I think
while it might seem really chaotic the
the flow of history is actually probably
going in a good direction what is what
are the most pressing things that you
think we need to embody in order to make
sure we're not just another collapsed
civilization
well I think we need to realize that the
whole planet is together we're all in
this together like our fate is the same
as everybody else on this planet and I'm
really you know maybe I'm jumping the
gun but I mean I think we really need to
get to Mars like as fast as possible
like that should be one of our number
one priorities honestly because we need
that kind of redundancy we need that
kind of decentralized system we're very
centralized we have we have blockchain
but humanity is on one big rock at this
point in time and that's a pretty
dangerous place to be yeah so adding a
couple celestial bodies decreases the
existential risk
exactly exactly okay cool yeah it's a
very cosmic yeah yeah we got to take
care of this house as well make sure
this house doesn't burn down is the so
interconnected with the eight billion of
us and all the species exactly let's get
into the journey you're born an organ
how did you pick up your interest in
neuroscience consciousness field as
you're growing up well I was a bit of a
loner growing up I was hugely into just
being on the Internet not really getting
into the gossip at school or anything
like that and I just was like a sponge
so I think I happened upon some show
called coast to coast am with like
George Noory
which is like an old like AM FM or an AM
radio show and they had the weirdest
guests on and I would sit sit at home in
middle school and just listen to these
people and then I heard one person
Stuart Hameroff
who's a MD in Arizona he was talking
about microtubules and consciousness and
this incredible stuff and I was like
this is amazing it's just something
about it just struck a nerve for me and
I couldn't really do anything because I
was like 13 14 at the time but I kind of
set it aside in my back of my brain and
then when I was about 23 I was like
what's Stuart Hameroff up to and so I
googled and I realized he was doing some
incredible neuromodulation using
ultrasound and I was like this is it
like I knew it back then when he was
talking about microtubules and I didn't
know what they were really and then I I
read about the the new ultrasound stuff
and I was like this is definitely gonna
be the future and what are microtubules
yeah microtubules are basically the
cytoskeletal scaffolding in all of your
cells so what makes your cells not just
amorphous blobs and able to hold a shape
that's like long neurons it's entirely
dependent mostly on microtubules which
extend out like these big straws
and Stuart Hameroff found out that these
tubulin that make it up are like these
self-assembling particles or are there
proteins and they they may be able to
process information individually so so
people think of a neuron is like the
central node of a of an information
processing system he discovered that it
might actually be like the strands
inside of it the microtubules that can
calculate really complex information so
so microtubules act as scaffolding
within cells to make them have a shape
yeah okay and and to be able to hold all
the interior complexity of the cell
interesting and are made of proteins the
scaffolding the microtubules are protein
they're made proteins yeah so they're
tubulin that that like arranged by
themselves and they can extend or shrink
and in your cortex you have these big
pyramidal cells which are like tons of
microtubules that are that are steady
for most of your life
and they kind of act as like information
processing centers and so it's a really
new theory it's been around for about 30
years now but it's a really cool theory
and then the same similar with cells for
the rest of our body as our neuronal
cells have microtubules as well yeah
every cell in your body has okay some of
them are more seemingly specialized in
the brain oh yeah in terms of how
they're arranged yeah yeah okay and then
okay so then at 23 when you were like
okay neuromodulation I'm really
interested in this then yet teacher take
us from that part of the journey yeah so
I essentially just I essentially just
dove in headfirst not really knowing
what I was getting myself into and I was
like okay this is it and I've started I
started my first business at 18 so I was
like there's got to be some opportunity
in here and it turns out that there was
and to essentially there's a huge gap in
terms of people who are able to bring
really smart
ultrasound physicists to the space of
clinical applications to actually
provide the hardware to research this
work so there's a big gap that I was
able to just fill really because of luck
really which is a good timing and market
and I saw an opportunity and so I was
able to essentially provide the
some of the equipment the ultrasound to
fill the gap in clinical neuroscience so
put me right in the fray in like you
know working with Jason Gwinnett II
Stuart Hameroff Jamie Tyler who's who
ran think for a while
you know so it just put me in this sense
central location to work with these
amazing people in neuroscience and and
engineering and so it really took off
from there within 12 months I was
already in China like manufacturing
ultrasounds so it was a pretty wild fast
fast meteoric rise and that was with
Berkeley ultrasound that was at Berkeley
okay okay and prior to that you were
doing ID techcamps yeah you were lead
instructing some C++ programming okay
and after teaching programming and game
design courses the Berkeley ultrasound
you said there was this is this is
called the brain simulation platforms
called lift up low intensity focused
ultrasound pulsing stimulator right
pulsations yeah pulsation okay yeah okay
and so yes it teach us about that and
then what that was like because this is
reversing depression helping treating
Alzheimer's and dementia all different
types of variable illness and disorders
of the brain including eradicate reverse
classic Parkinson's so many kangs can
potentially be healed with this yeah so
walk us through what this was like this
is yeah 2013 was the start of it yeah so
at end of 2013 and really got served in
2014 and by 2015 I was in China
manufacturing a really a perfect
culmination of all the requests from the
clinical applications that were coming
in for they're like well we want to
treat depression we want to treat PTSD
Alzheimer's dementia is we had to take
their specifications and you know see
what we could engineer in terms of
something with a small portable
affordable easy to program you know
there's a lot of pain points in this
industry it's very complicated stuff and
so I wanted to try and make it simple
enough so that you know any any grad
student could kind of dive in and start
getting into the end of the work and so
culminating in my my I think was about
five months in China and Shenzhen
through the help of shoutout to Ryan
Bethencourt and esos ventures and and
Sean O'Sullivan for helping me get in
there and so we've manufactured this
really slick portable small research
device they could allow you to like
program ultrasound stimulate the brain
and do all kinds of amazing stuff and so
from that it really opened up this door
just to see like what really could be
possible here with ultrasound and so
through that you know I started really
realizing that you it's not just the
brain that you can stimulate but neurons
run through your entire body and so I've
recently come across the fact that you
can actually stimulate other parts of
your cranial nerves trigeminal nerves
and other parts of your body with with
ultrasound really effectively and we
have some assets to start showing here
two that I think might help us yeah yeah
okay so you see the what you're
manufacturing in 2015 was this portion
here yeah so that's a transducer that's
what the ultrasound comes out so I was
working on those and the electronics
that drive it yeah yeah and making it
easily programmable Kretz
okay yeah to change things like the like
the Hertz the frequency yes
yeah the intensity the pulse rate the
frequencies in some cases you can change
the focal distance so you can you know
steer the ultrasound beam this is going
into the deep brain as you know one of
the applications I'm currently looking
at right now for pretty similar to what
Jason GoDaddy's doing in terms of
mindfulness meditation that can stuff
mm-hmm
that's a current application and then so
when you guys were figuring out to
manufacture this was it a was it kind of
like we're gonna we're gonna create this
for like clinical use was it for
personal use clinical use yeah and then
to eradicate some of the ailments that
we have with their health yeah it was
kind of a thing yeah okay and it all
started originally in
a temporal window so right here so
really above your temple right above
your eyes on your forehead kind of and
so that was to treat depression that
starts in the prefrontal cortex there's
this weird D synchronization that
happens so your two lobes your left and
your right will start pulsing at
different frequencies and that's what's
a big indicator of depression actually
so the original usage of ultrasound was
to try and regulate the both hemispheres
to synchronize at the same time in the
alpha band and that was some work kind
of pioneered by John Allen dr. John
Allen and uh in Arizona as well so he's
a he's like the mentor to Jason Kennedy
mm-hmm and so that's really where it
started with Stuart Hameroff and and all
those people and so then the
distribution of this through Berkeley
ultrasound ended up getting into the
hands of some you guys ended up
manufacturing getting into clinics yeah
yeah so mostly in Tucson and you know
kind of some clinics around the world in
small limited applications because
there's a lot of you know there's a lot
of issues with the FDA and it's it's a
it's a very advanced it's on the very
edge of research so there's a lot of you
know there's a lot of work that needs to
be done still yeah yeah to make sure
that we're not harming people by
accident the exact technology is yet
exactly what we say it's gonna be doing
yeah all that kind of stuff that it's
tested properly yeah yeah so then that
was that was five years of doing that
yeah okay and then we have yes so it is
another example and what that would look
like
damn this looks like it's yeah much more
like 2030 or something yeah this looks
like a satellite from space going to
your brain yeah this is just a you know
a mock representation of what that might
look like with with ultrasound so yeah
you know pretty much the primary
applications right now that people are
looking at is really taking a single
transducer and putting it deep into your
brain to try and effect like the limbic
structures the basal ganglia
some of that work is around
you know your ego your sense of self
rumination which are things that really
contribute to depression like your sense
of you know are you good are you good
enough do you are you you know so part
of this is to try and turn that down a
little bit just try and make somebody
somebody's lived experience a little bit
more comfortable mm-hmm so that's kind
of the current application a lot of
people are looking at mm-hmm yeah yeah
okay and so this is just some you know
this is kind of what what it looks like
when the ultrasound goes into the skull
and into the brain so you can see kind
of there's kind of a small targeting
area
it's called sonication and yeah so this
is this is some pioneering work on on
how to stimulate the brain using
ultrasound mm-hmm
damn so it's a lot of that the the
rumination on if I'm good enough
that's usually what gets you said it's
at left and right temporal lobes are not
in synchrony and that's yeah in in some
cases yeah that's that's seemingly what
John Allen discovered and so if we look
at this one it's a little bit cut off on
the edges but some of the similar work
will be done right now okay yeah so some
of the work so the original work was
hitting the prefrontal cortex with
ultrasound to try and regulate the left
and right part of the prefrontal cortex
but now the search is actually deeper
into the limbic system so it's
essentially looking at you know
regulating people who don't feel safe or
feeling unloved or feeling bad emotions
these kinds of things so really
regulating like stress and
fight-or-flight response so people can
feel kind of I guess better in their
body to feel more centered and more
grounded and so that this is where this
is where a lot of the research research
is right now so yeah okay okay yeah
because going in yeah deeper is harder
to the limbic than it is closer to the
surface level yeah yeah of the cortex
exact
yeah exactly okay all right and then you
have the network so the next Assateague
shows some of those limbic
infrastructures yeah yeah so this is
this is more of a cross section so the
limbic system is really represented in
this very centrally located part of your
brain it's like hippocampus this is like
where memory emotion fear stress a lot
of this stuff resides the the sense of
this self even resides in here as well
and so it's a really important area to
stimulate but whereas most of my
colleagues are attempting to enter into
the brain through the very top down and
trying to penetrate through the skull
and a lot of matter there's actually a
lot of work showing that there's another
way into the limbic system and it's not
through the skull it's actually through
the cranial nerves that enter in from
underneath your head and so that's
really where where I've actually started
shifting a lot of my attention is to how
do we get into this is like considered
the back door of the brain that's very
under under under explored but there's
huge potential in that area yeah there's
there's you have 12 total cranial me
yeah yeah 12 total couriers in the vase
there's the 10th yeah so the vagus nerve
is the tenth cranial nerve and okay
let's show the next slide too with this
yeah yeah yeah so the the so basically
the this is an this is a shot from
underneath the the brains you're looking
up and you can see there's a lot of lot
of these nerves so essentially the the
tenth cranial nerve right here X is the
vagus nerve so it regulates heart lungs
your stomach your your your your throat
so how you speak
tons of stuff even reproduction hormones
your level of stress safety there's a
lot of stuff is tied up in that one
nerve branch so it's pretty much a
direct input directly into your brain
and this the networks are very
interconnected so it's a direct access
to your limbic system and these all run
up the spinal cord so these are separate
from the spinal cord so this is run up
the spinal cord right yes there's
so the parasympathetic nervous system
which is your sense of safety generally
speaking it's the ventral vagal that
runs outside of the spine of the spinal
column and then the sympathetic nervous
chain which is the fight-or-flight chain
which is where you feel scared in fear
actually runs to the spinal branch
because then that enables you to flight
if you need to yeah motor function and
it's the most important thing to be
protected to so if you think of you know
predators in the wild slashing at you
not to give you too much of a graphic
image but if you if you're if your
instinct is to survive you would want
your most important functions of running
away and finding food to be as protected
as possible so there in the spine
they're very protected and there's like
some of the these cranial nerves are
known as just sympathetic nervous system
no no so the sympathetic is kind of the
chain that connects to a lot of your
organs that kick you india into high
gear so making your heart beat a lot
faster to release adrenaline to make
your eyes widen so you can like really
see things but the cranial nerves don't
separate into sympathetic and
parasympathetic separate and do their
you know it's more of a classification
of what they do yeah yeah yeah and so
then the vagus nerve is this wandering
nerve within the central there's two of
them
there's a left in there and a right and
then there's a there's a dorsal and then
eventual okay so ventral means it comes
out of the front and then dorsals out of
the back part of your brainstem and
there's a left and a right side and it's
it's really a wandering nerve that's
what the word means Vegas is Latin for
wander wander and that's how it connects
to the yeah so this is it it wanders all
the way through your body and so there's
a there's so many graphics I could show
you but it really does connect to so
many of these other parts of your body
yeah let's go to that next one which is
the 10th yeah yeah yeah exactly
so here's kind of a overall view of the
tenth cranial nerve so again this is
where it exits from your brainstem and
it runs down here to your throat so it
controls your ability to speak
it's a swallow as well it influences
hearing it influences your lungs
brachiation how much oxygen you breathe
the
heart your liver your stomach your
spleen your pancreas controls blood
glucose levels insulin release due
digestion there's a whole bunch of stuff
that's very intertwined with this this
vagus nerve so and basically the vagus
nerve is two main things so there's
afferent cell or efferent lines that go
down and afferent which go up so
afferent is 20% of the nerve fibers and
that means that your brain sends signals
down about 20% of the time but your your
vagus nerve reports to 80% of the time
up into your brain and so this tells you
if you're hungry if you're if you're
full if you're tired if you're thirsty
if you're horny if you're any number of
things that are connected to this if you
feel sick if you like you gotta puke all
that stuff is reported on your vagus
nerve do you know yeah yeah so it's it's
a it's a ridiculously important part of
your of your function and so we know a
lot about it because they used to do a
lot of surgery on this nerve to actually
to cut it for certain kinds of disorders
so like if you had if you got like
ulcers a lot they would actually snip
your vagus nerve right down here it's
like a very common thing but what they
found is that in the in the populations
in Scandinavia that actually had this
surgical procedure done to snip their
vagus nerve from the stomach down that
they had a way fewer incidences of
Parkinson's disease and some people like
well what's going on with that and they
found out that most likely Parkinson
starts in your stomach and then it
travels up your vagus nerve into your
brain well yeah it's really important
it's a really important ERV so you gotta
really take care of it so so so much of
what's going on in our bodies organ
systems are actually being communicated
up so our brain only becomes aware of
them because the organs are
communicating it through the vagus nerve
up to the brain
exactly and then we make our next
decision based on on that feeling that
we're
yeah yeah so it's super important for
and and one of the other things was in
terms of so there can be like surgical
accidents or whatever he's in a car
accident where it gets severed a little
bit closer to the head and this is the
one of the interesting things is that
they found that people had a severed
vagus nerve higher up had a way higher
incidence of schizophrenia mm-hmm so it
means that the the brain is essentially
waiting for input from the vagus nerve
it's not getting anything and it's
hallucinating inputs and that's that's
possibly a reason why you know people
can hallucinate when they have you know
schizophrenia damn some dysfunction of
the vagus nerve I'm excited to talk
about stimulating this as well as yeah
totally let's do on the factors
affecting breathing which is the next
one yeah so so for a lot of people
watching you might be like how do i
stimulate my vagus nerve it's it's
actually really pretty easy breathing
with your diaphragm so you can take deep
breaths like that's kind of a starter
way to do it and then another way is to
breathe in and hold and this is called
of a salver maneuver and you actually
squeeze in your chest and you kind of do
this squeezing method right here in your
your chest cavity here with your
diaphragm and then you slow exhale and
so that's actually doing is it's it's in
a way pinching the part of your vagus
nerve down here that runs through your
diaphragm that holds your lungs in and
out so that's like a very easy way to
stimulate your vagus nerve I really
recommend for most people who just want
to see like what it's like to get
started do you think it has something to
do with the amount of oxygen that we
take in that stimulates our body through
a like a much deeper breath and then we
hold it in yeah and then we're giving it
more time to absorb rather than the
immediate like shallow breaths
definitely that the oxygenation is
really key so and yeah it's a very
interconnected system so more breathing
expands your
Branka in your in your lungs and your
vagus nerve runs through that so it's
getting stimulated your releases more
acetylcholine which helps down regulate
inflammation down regulate stress
response to things so overall it's a
really good thing but yes so oxygenation
is really good a good part of it and I
think people just need to breathe more
people just if you look at them they're
just like mmm they're hypertensive not
breathing and that causes all kinds of
issues mm-hmm yeah you have a deep
connection of breath yeah yeah yeah okay
mmm-hmm all right so yeah in terms of
other ways to stimulate your vagus nerve
where it gets more invasive where it's
not more it's not very natural as
external though this is still no this is
this is actually under the skin this is
under the skin PS so that you can you
can do this outside of the skin too
right you can in a way yeah yeah this is
a very this is this was FDA approved for
treating epilepsy okay so for people who
really really needed help they found
that stimulating the vagus nerve during
an epileptic fit actually reduced the
severity of epilepsy mm-hmm of an above
like a seizure um Wow yeah so it's very
you know this this network goes all the
way up to your brain so yeah so
essentially there are I don't know
probably about forty to fifty thousand
people walking around with this
implanted in their body already already
damn yeah and so how many millions of
people have epilepsy around the world
something like that it's well I mean I
think it's like a hundred and twenty
thousand or potentially have this okay
it's not it that that would be that I've
looked at the market size for this and
it's a closer to about 120 okay a
thousand maybe a little bit closer to
200,000 worldwide oakerson like that so
it's a it's a relatively small market in
terms of people who are able to have
this implanted but I mean this is kind
of a first step in terms of like I think
transhumanism like this is directly
modifying a very important part of your
neurology so you're putting in a pulse
generator with like the lithium ion
battery something like that and then
that
connects via like electrode um to live
wraps around the vagus nerve and it's
called a cuff it like wraps around a bit
like this like fingers yeah and then it
only activates when usually like a
remote activation when I'm feeling when
I'm having an epileptic episode I'd ice
to me you have a watch on it has a
magnet and you run it across under your
skin and so you can run it across so if
you feel like you're having it then you
can activate it Wow yeah yeah so you can
on-demand stimulate your vagus nerve and
so the odd thing about this was that
even though some people it worked really
really well so it's very very good
procedure in the for the most part but
people who even they didn't have any
reduction in epilepsy noticed that like
their major depressive disorder actually
went away after about six weeks of
having this installed so that got people
to wonder could the vagus nerve be
related to depression also yeah and so
through a lot of research they did
clinical trials and they found that for
people who don't have epilepsy but have
major depressive disorder like
treatment-resistant depression
essentially that it actually helps treat
depression very well so the FDA approved
it for that as well now so this can dis
can treat depression and epilepsy and
eating disorders now they're doing this
this for because the vagus nerve
regulates your sense of satiation hunger
that it's all it's all in there a lot of
important stuff in there I'm curious as
to this being a like a like an appendage
like a physical appendage that we bring
from from outside then to solve kind of
what is a what could be viewed as like a
second order it's like a symptom of like
what is like a first principled
disconnection from like nature like
something yeah so yeah so what do you
what are your thoughts about that
I mean I've definitely this is this is a
wife long question like when you deal
with technology that can help people
like you say well should we should we
even be in a society that needs to
create technology to help these problems
that
could likely be related to lifestyle and
the environment yeah ezal being stuck
inside of the cubicles all the time and
i think these things are definitely good
questions to ask but the reality is like
this is easy this is this is something
that we can have implanted in you like
pretty darn fast and then from this
creates the change the the the room for
change so people have these kinds of
things they knows they're they're going
out in nature more often they're this is
life changing kind of stuff okay so it's
harder to repattern someone's behaviors
towards like source or spirit than it is
to potentially add something in that
makes them more trans human like that
that can maybe create that deeper
interconnected connection yeah
damn that our artificial is the key word
for the future artificial it does seem
to be that way yes absolutely
hey whatever whatever it takes yeah I
mean the thing is like when it comes to
epilepsy the reason that was approved is
because epilepsy is not something that
you want to live with it sucks yeah life
altering yeah any can't is it's not just
as easy as saying go get more trees in
sunlight and ocean yeah for your
epilepsy yeah I can't say you know you
have epilepsy go eat more dirt get more
like bacteria you know yes it's very
complicated totally yeah the way the
physiology interacts with the
environments very complicated yeah it is
crazy that it's just such a crazy thing
like that the first order disconnection
from from source of spirit is now like
augmented by technology to maybe get us
closer to that and towards the unity
it's a very interesting dance that we're
playing with with the tech very
interesting dance
it is fascinating well we fail to do it
ourselves yeah yeah period yeah and if
we don't get it right within if we don't
take those steps they're gonna do it for
us don't ask me who they are
but uh
they're working out yeah if we yeah
that's it it's D that's a good way to
put it if we fail biologically to
recognize the interconnectedness
ourselves then the civilization will
collapse unless something comes in to
save the day and maybe this is what's
coming in to save the day what's what
Sterling's working on and everybody else
that we have on this show are doing just
that I may hold the key yeah this is
this is a key technology and I do want
to say like you know I have a friend who
works at Stanford who is a he works with
this technology and he'll jump down my
throat if I don't say like you know
epilepsy is not I don't think curable by
getting in nature or anything like that
yeah necessarily there's some there's
some genetic things that are happening
yeah when you say yeah when you have
that yeah you were pressing on your
amygdala and you're gonna kill your wife
and your kids there's like there's no
way yeah there's some times where you
know a really technological intervention
is very helpful yeah and there's not
really like you know any amount of
meditation that you can do that yeah
they kept like any modernization and
also yeah and the the argument of nature
is that 11 it's that person's time to
set that is that that's part of the
consciousness experiences you have to go
through that process of suffering and
committing that right act and going
through that versus the argument of the
technologist is that we can eradicate
that suffering we don't need that
something to happen we we can prevent it
that person can have live a healthy life
and then that's kind of going against
the natural of native what's natural
role exactly so it's a very interesting
complicated conversation that we've been
having the last like a couple weeks
especially about like that grow of
indigenous wisdom and the role of
Technology yeah it's hard to say I mean
you know I think we'll get that into
this later but we were part of this big
super organism yeah and we're all trying
to find an optimal path forward so some
people will try an optimal path that
doesn't end up working and some people
will try the path that does work and so
we're all like I said we're all in this
together this is all a big global
superorganism system
[Music]
so yeah let's let's hit the tenth asset
let's do it what's going on yeah okay so
in terms of you know some other areas
where this electrical stimulation of the
vagus nerve is working is really
regulating inflammation in the body and
regulating very like metabolism style
processes so when you stimulate the
vagus nerve it actually interrupts the
process of your macrophages in your
spleen nothing it too complicated but it
stops them from releasing inflammatory
cytokines like tumor necrosis factor
alpha and interleukin 6 which are you
know we know that those actually help
destroy not help that actually destroy
healthy tissue if you have too much of
it so people who are overstressed
you have an overabundance in this
inflammatory cytokine and so vagus nerve
stimulation releases more acetylcholine
ACH
which actually changes the DNA
expression in the macrophages to be it's
basically like meditation is is one of
the things that helps but vagus nerve
stimulation also does very similar stuff
and so that's actually being clinically
explored right now how can we reduce
inflammation and people because it's one
thing to get your mind on top of the
stress but it's another thing is if
you've been stressed for the last three
years your body is just flooded with
with cytokines you got to take care of
that stuff too and so you know it's like
you don't have much time if you've been
stressed out for three years and your
body's been pumping out inflammation
because it thinks that there's like an
intruder and you're in your body which
it's really just a more of a
psychological intruder which is still
real in that sense then you have to deal
with that too and it's kind of like
immediately as fast as possible you have
to deal with that so
while so actually yet city great
decreasing the inflammation within the
body through vagus nerve stimulation
yeah yeah you know yes the biohacking
yeah and so in terms of other ways to by
a hack if you look at the next slide
you'll see that you know human
connection is a really great way to
actually stimulate the vagus nerve like
we're we are social creatures the vagus
nerve is what is feeling in our heart in
our in our body in our gut you know that
gut feeling about a person that's all
your vagus nerve telling your brain how
it feels about another person we're
about a situation it's called neuro
ception so it's your you have perception
through your eyes and ears and taste and
touch but your body also has a
perception as well so yeah you know when
you hug somebody and it feels really
good that's essentially like this vagus
nerve telling you like okay I feel safe
you should feel safe now your brain gun
okay I feel safe so it's you know it's a
it works together they all work together
yeah the the the also the vagus nerve
going in connecting so many of these key
organs within us and then the body the
body like so that's kind of one of the
Dover's just the indications we get
within our mind that we get these warm
and fuzzies that yeah this is a trust
yeah exactly is a big part of it and
this has a lot to do with oxytocin as
well absolutely yeah yeah Alexson
release totally okay and reduction in
like adrenaline we know yeah cortisol
yeah don't think those make you feel
like you're unsafe unsafe yeah okay
alright and then and so I'll kind of go
over this kind of briefly which is that
there are so okay there's the three main
systems that your your vagus system can
occupy in terms of like energy is the
the top one is the most desirable one
called the ventral vagal which is where
you feel safe connected you feel like
you're part of something bigger that's
really our social engagement system
that's what you want to be activated but
if you are not feeling able to engage or
connect with people or if you feel
afraid or or
for whatever reason then your body will
activate this sympathetic nervous system
and that's where you know you back to
your spinal column of your your
sympathetic nervous chain and then I'll
start stimulating organs to release
adrenaline and start feelings freaked
out maybe you should run maybe you
should you know fight maybe you need to
fight somebody and this starts
influencing your brain as well because
your brain is part of that system and so
it'll start to map
you know imagining like scenarios where
you're fighting or running away and so
this this is a chain that starts it's a
it's a chain reaction it's a loop so
your body feels unsafe your brain
imagines what you would do in that
situation and your brain can't tell the
difference between imagined or real in a
lot of cases if I visualize something it
can almost feel real in my body and so
then your body reacts your brain reacts
so people can get stuck in this
sympathetic system and you know that's
where people are like under this
constant stress and once you get enough
stress and you feel like there's no
button or thing you can do to press or
you can't escape it you'll your body
will essentially get into a place where
it's it's passive its and mobilized so
that's what that's essentially what
happens when you go into dorsal and you
just lay down and you say it's no use
it's hopeless it's like total down in
the depth of depression whoa because
your body is just like I can't fight my
way out of this I can't connect with
people so I'm gonna go and shut down I'm
gonna maintain as many resources as I
can whoa I'm going to hibernation whoa
and then what are they and then the the
vagus nerve is related to all three of
these so then these well these three so
that it kind of does it does it kind of
like pick and choose between the three
immobilization mobilization and signal
signaling system like yeah it does it
kind of yeah yeah so the so the
anatomist that discovered the vagus
nerve his name was Galen he was a Roman
like guy he was a ramen do't dude taking
apart warriors or whatever who were
fighting are they the Centurions and he
discovered this nerve and he classified
these chains as the one thing you know
they're not really the one thing they're
part of the vagus nerve system but they
once they looked at it closer they're
like they're actually kind of like a
little bit separate so there's dorsal
vagal a separate from ventral vagal but
they are sort of in the same kind of
they connect in the same area of the
brain okay how did he acquire the
cadavers uh well he was dissecting pigs
and he was he was in Rome at the
Colosseum so he was dissecting dead
fighters actually fighters yeah - yeah
yeah yeah and he was and it was funny I
was reading this last night not funny
but some of them would have slash marks
right on their neck so it would have
severed their vagus nerve and they had
weird symptoms that developed from that
and so he was able to kind of detect
that you know these nerves are really
important for feeling relaxed so these
people were like constantly on edge
because they had some damage there so
that's you know I know where we can get
some specimens if you want to you know
have a lab the city no II understand a
lot more about this than he did that was
about 208 exactly that's why I'm saying
now's a good time to experiment once
again with human being it's it's also
yeah it's it's not thinking about the
the what we were doing to discover the
initial parts of the internal operating
systems in the past and like what
technology we have now to discover the
internal parts of the operating system
that we live in yeah this is this I feel
like we have been flow between the
different states here so frequently yeah
yeah your body basically is in one of
these at either time for the most part
but there is one where so if you for
instance are activating dorsal and
ventral you can have this really intense
feeling of safety with another person
mm-hmm that's very visceral
and so you can actually activate ventral
and dorsal at the same time yeah and
that's a really coveted kind of coveted
thing and then you can also do that's
maybe when you're in love or something
that's when you're in like deep deep mad
love with somebody that's like the
that's like the the pinnacle of what
your system can provide pretty much yeah
yeah okay cool and then let's move on to
the oh yeah the pop the polyvagal theory
right okay and so this is the
recognition that you essentially climb a
ladder of the the vagus nerve
essentially in terms of you are a dorsal
vagal if you just can't cope with
anything and then you can move your way
up to sympathetic where you're like I'm
mobilized I'm ready to fight maybe run
and then it takes that to get to this
place of feeling connected to the bigger
picture of part of the world and these
are these are kind of like growing out
of our our evolutionary history as well
so there's the reptilian brain and
that's like fighting in flight and
fighting there's the cortex which is
more of the ventral vagal the the
ventral vagus the the vagus that runs
that activates when you're in love is a
very is a very new structure it's more
of a mammalian structure rather than
like an old antiquated reptilian thing
so then what is the vagus nerve doing in
the three examples here when it's in the
state of feeling connected the greater
world right this is what we were
discussing the last one as well the
interconnectedness between those two
yeah yeah exactly so so ventral vagal
essentially does a lot of stuff to
physiologically and so we're gonna do a
little bit of a demo to show you how to
actually determine where you are
you owe us - um so in the next slide
we'll look at this so you can
essentially determine how your vagus
nerve is operating based on how your
heart rate is and Hart how you how much
variability you have in your heart rate
okay so I have this tool that I brought
it's a demo characters from a company
called elite HRV and so it's a little
finger sensor that you put your finger
into like this okay like or sense and
there's an app so I'll show this here
okay yeah and just hold it steady so Ron
can can yeah yeah so hold this steady so
to measure your heart rate variability
aka your vagus nerve health okay you
want to breathe in when the circle gets
bigger and then breathe out when it gets
smaller
do we need a click start to I'm not it's
no it's sensing it it's Auto sensing it
now so basically my variability score is
about 55 57 okay and that's a little bit
low but I definitely say because I'm on
a live stream I know that we are you
know in mobilization with a heart rate
of a hundred and a variability of about
55 okay yeah pretty much which is pretty
high I'd say I'm definitely yeah ready
ready for this just went down to Sony 9
it seems like it's kind of jumping quite
a bit yeah yeah exactly so if I'm
talking and moving around it definitely
affects it so okay and what do you learn
from seeing the measuring heart rate
variability related the vagus nerve yeah
so if you're in really if you're in a
really stressed out state your vagus
nerve your ventral vagus nerve is not
activating as much as it should and so
your vagus nerve connects to the bottom
side of your heart and it's called the
vagal brake hmm so it puts a break on
your heartbeat mmm so essentially if
your vagus your ventral vagus nerve is
working then it'll send up a short burst
to your heart to slow your heart rate
down and then the vague then the ventral
vagus nerve will will SAP activity and
not activate as much and then your heart
rate will increase again so in people
who are hypertensive what's going to
what you're gonna see is that there's no
variability at all which means that
their ventral vagal system they're their
social engagement system is just not
working at all it's just not activating
so it means that they're probably in in
sympathetic nervous chain activation
meaning that they're like they're in
fight-or-flight and so that's what you
would say so you'd see like pretty much
a flat line across here and this
variability number might be down like
two 13 or 20 or something for like
really hypertensive people and that
means you're in a state of like your
sympathetic nervous system your
fight-or-flight your Pandya panic yeah
when your heart rate variability is just
barely right varied at all yeah and like
super relaxed a super varied yes yeah so
what if you're relaxed your heart beat
should should sound like a jet
song such as like don't don't do doom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
so it goes faster and slower with your
breathing yeah so when you breathe in
your heart rate increases and when you
breathe out that's when your vagus nerve
your ventral vagus nerve slows your
heart rate down so it's slower and then
it the chain continues like that so
that's a good sign you you want to have
that so you can do it for yourself at
home if you can measure your heartbeat
you can take your finger fingers and put
it on your pulse on your yeah yeah yeah
or you I was just feeling it right here
even yeah just just in your in your
throat here yeah or right here this spot
right here this soft spot your heart's
just below that and so if you breathe in
your heart will increase and then it
should slow down might even skip a beat
if you're really relaxed yeah yeah yeah
so so that's great that's heart rate
variability is so important to be able
to feel our heartbeat yeah yeah and so
so in terms of you know that's kind of
what that looks like and so if we go to
the next slide the company elite HRV
released some data on twenty four
thousand seven hundred and sixty four
users of this same technology and what
you'll notice is that it's it's a bell
curve distribution and you know the
average is about pretty much where I was
I'm about fifty five during this
interview normally I'm about sixty seven
seventy you know if I'm just sitting or
whatever and so what I've what I've
noticed from this is that people
influence each other so we have a social
engagement system so I'm pinging you
you're paying me yeah we're influencing
each other in terms of stress level
because we look to our nearest neighbor
to see is there something we should be
afraid of yeah it's kind of like the
global brain might like mass psychology
you know the mob mentality yeah we're
all pinging each other so what this
shows for me what I read out of this is
that we're all kind of globally
influencing each other's heart rate
variability you know it would be weird
if we saw like a like a dumbbell kind of
distribution when it was like one
population down here
one population down here you might see
that if you compared like somewhere in
in a war-torn country versus like the
the effluent West sure sure you might
see this big distribution yeah yeah yeah
but it's this kind of localized area for
heart rate variability and so what that
says to me is that local populations
influence their own level of stress
either up or down and so that's kind of
this idea that you know we think of our
brain as the node in the network but our
vagus nerve is kind of a social network
node that remembers people in some way
it can it has kind of has a storage
system of like these are triggers that
make me feel upset or scared or these
are things that make me feel safe and so
these are kind of things that that are
like relegated to the vagus nerve so
that's what that's this is the what this
shows me yeah you in like a light like
you're you're giving this perspective of
the of being able to think about things
like a global brain and the way that you
know we are engaging with each other
right now when we can like butterfly
effect are like states of happiness or
stress on to each other and how that
affects our heart rate variability you
can see it like on a global scale areas
that are maybe more relaxed or a higher
heart higher heart rate variability zand
exactly more stressed on lower heart
rate variability x' yeah so if you can
influence other people around you to
towards relaxed states joyful states etc
then that's these are the big things we
can do with spreading memes of that
style as well exactly
yeah using a neuro tech tools to get us
further towards the relaxed states yeah
yeah and so this is kind of like people
talk about raising consciousness high
like the upward spiral this is kind of
an indication that you know I guess
maybe if we measured this 100 years ago
we didn't have the technology to do that
but it probably would have been lower
probably would have been a lower HRV and
I don't know for sure but I think in the
future as people start kind of engaging
more socially connecting
feeling safer feeling more optimistic
more creative more curious that the HRV
of the globe will actually start inching
up and so that'll be kind of an
indicator of global health but the meant
the the mental health of the entire
planet could be represented with this
one number potentially yeah yeah whoa
yeah do you think the mental health of a
planet can be represented with the HRV
score potentially yeah Wow yes yeah I
mean if you're HRV is low there's a lot
of other things that are happening
you're high inflammation I stress more
apt to like maybe be violent to act out
those kinds of things but if you're more
creative you're more able to solve
problems and we need problem solvers
rather than people complaining about the
existing order I mean we need we
literally need people who are able to
get into flow state able to kind of tap
into some source some creativity and
really think of big solutions to the
problems we have today mm-hmm it's not
gonna come from like being stressed you
know this kind of lower level feels like
Earth's global health is like the
planetary global health is like further
down yeah yeah right now yeah and you
have to know this is these are people
who went out and purchased the elite HRV
fingertip so we don't have we don't
really have the global thing yet it's
possible I mean most of these iPhones
have the ability to detect your
heartbeat with their camera yes that's
possible their facial recognition yeah
facial recognition apps you know there's
a there's a big ecosystem that can be
coming yeah yeah and so so this is this
is another thing I just want to touch on
this cool factor which is there's a lot
of really impressive things that can
happen for your brain if you stimulate
your vagus nerve either through
breathing through exercise cold showers
work really well yeah like you know you
can take a cold shower take a cold
plunge
cryotherapy those kinds of things are
really good for stimulating this -
ventral vagal but one thing that I found
recently was an article showing that
vagus nerve stimulation increases BDNF
which is a basically a growth hormone
for neurons and this is a big indication
in people who are suffering from
depression is they have a huge decrease
in BDNF brain-derived neurotrophic
factor so if you stimulate your vagus
nerve BDNF will go up and more neurons
will start growing in your hippocampus
which is where you know short episodic
memory resides and neuroplasticity
anywhere in your brain is pretty much a
good thing so if we go to the next slide
there's some actual pictures
so on the left is colored DCX cells
which are related to microtubules
actually and on the right is just sham
stimulation so this just shows that if
you do the VNS stimulation you can have
really positive growth of important
neurons in your hippocampus and if we go
to the next one we can see that so this
is actually the VNS that's the Sham it's
switched okay but you see more BDNF
cells so actually a pretty pretty big
rise and this is okay I believe just
shortly after and then after I think
this is after three weeks of stimulation
okay oh every day every day okay yeah
yeah yeah so it's um you know it's not
just like neck down it's also neck up
yeah there's a lot of good stuff that
happens in your head yeah as well and
this is this is a transcranial this is
actually with electrodes implanted in
your neck okay
yeah implanted in yeah so within that
with that little that little yeah yeah
but this is unwrapped this is on rats
okay
electrode in the neck on the vagus that
coil on the Vegas yeah exactly
okay yeah in research but there are
there are developing technologies that
can actually let you stimulate your
vagus nerve without surgery so things
that go that are handheld devices that
you put over your vagus nerve yeah that
are like electrical or some with light
some with ultrasound yeah so there's a
Larry yeah there's a lot of development
in this direction stimulate with light
and then what would be the result of the
increase in BDNF
yeah so basically the BDNF would make
you more resilient more more able to
respond appropriately to new situations
so more neuroplasticity means you're
able to learn from your mistakes better
okay it's really you know
antidepressants basically grow BDNF in
the brain we get smarter because you
better memory yeah
so the last one is yeah this was this
was the animated gif that we've yeah so
this is just this is just a filler slide
I want to throw in but it kind of points
to kind of where I see this all going
which is that you know I think we're
coming up to a future where we have an
increase in machine learning artificial
intelligence EEG brain stimulation
there's so much going on that's in these
different pathways yeah then I'm really
starting to see this desire to merge
this stuff together and so I have this
kind of a unique position to see where
this is going to have been in it for so
long and yeah so essentially the future
over the next probably five to ten years
will be developing a real-time brain
stimulation system that is multi-channel
so be like different channels of
ultrasound all over your brain and sort
of one big targeting those tiny little
ultrasounds yes yeah adjacent to eg yeah
so reading the brain and stimulating the
brain yes putting it into a machine
learning algorithm seeing your brain in
real-time from the machine and
stimulating it in real-time
yes almost like a self-driving car so
you think of like the mobile eye system
do is pretty crazy in a car in a Tesla
like auto driving essentially just but
powering the brain so now you can
reading through EEG and then having a
FML I'll go
figure out how you want to stimulate to
get you and yourself into a flow state
or into wherever you want to go and then
just I mean the amount of control that
we have at that yeah just like it's
insane yeah so probably where it'll
start is taking a retaking a recording
of your brain in one five-minute segment
and then telling the machine to figure
out how to make that happen again by
driving it so it's like just doing a
recording of somebody driving down the
freeway and taking in the data training
it and then saying okay now we're taking
off the training wheels and we want you
to try and drive that brain activity to
look like how it looked like before so
that's kind of the future that's kind of
the short-term future
but then long-term 50 years from now
this will be all you know integrated in
your head but probably in about 10-15
years this will become so we have six
layers of the human cortex and these are
what makes us human basically the cortex
is like our human part of our brand this
will become the seventh layer of the
cortex yeah yeah yeah just a little just
an extra cortical layer that's
upgradable because you can't upgrade
your cortex because you can't expand
your brain you can't get your skull we
can't do that yet
maybe we can do stem cell injections to
grow your cortex bigger or something
make it more dense but this is
upgradable so you can you can put more
Nvidia graphics cards out here yeah and
that that all connects and powers the
machine learning algorithm yeah and so
these these will actually co-developed
with each other so your brain will learn
that it's actually being influenced
externally and so your brain will start
to figure out how to do it you think
that we're gonna end up wearing the
seventh layer at our you know
organizations and in our homes and that
will certain people will choose to not
wear it and just be left behind or yeah
what's the I think it'll be common in
brainstorming sessions so if you really
need to like you know put on your
thinking cap this will literally be the
epitome of a thinking cap so it'd
probably be executive board meetings
where they're like okay we really need
to think this you know because the the
rapid pace in which decisions need to be
made like no mind wandering you have
right super focused super creative super
flow super super empathy yeah yeah so
this would be like Jeff Bezos will be
like contracting us and be like okay I
need I need the thinking cap it will
have a mobile van that goes to his
office or you know maybe they'll have
these in every executive suite at the
top of every building something like
that so it'll be like a thinking room
for 30 minute thinking room there you go
like if a sales top at the Salesforce
tower they'll have a neuroscience lab
where executives take an elevator up sit
for 30 minutes process immense amounts
of data and then go take a nap and
spit out their answers after that
something like that it's probably well
this is wrong this reminds me I need to
change my name to 1110 one 966 r2 - five
nine Wow I mean it's not it's um we're
already doing that if you think of it
like our cell phones our cell phones act
as an external processor yeah we're yeah
so yeah this is just just an extension
of that
this reminds this reminds me - that some
of the thoughts about the indigenous are
that just like little brother be careful
with the way that you play with the
godlike technology because the
civilization could collapse from your
thinking that you know everything and
that you're gonna know did they say
could or will usually said could well
we're already at risk of Hoonah I mean
who knows what's gonna happen in the
next 50 years I mean I think we just
like I said I mean I think the solutions
will come from like incredible leaps in
in creativity and development and I
think this I think we do kind of at this
point needs some help because we it's
almost like there is an element of
humans versus the machine in one way but
it's like we do need to develop with
machines as well we are gonna need to
kind of get their help so this is kind
of how I see potentially this is how it
will help us not be against us
interesting so there could there could
be the added layer of machine
intelligence to make sure that the
civilization doesn't collapse correct
interesting yeah yeah fair point yeah
you might have like an Oracle class that
just kind of sits with these all the
time that like you know the kind of that
global the the elite thinking unit I'm
sure sure people who are born this is
getting it way out there this is like
super sci-fi [ __ ] but and I don't really
know I'm just thinking on my feet but
it's like tomorrow in terms of cosmic
time yeah
in terms of when this could happen but
it on you know we I think about it like
I know people who just spend about eight
hours scrolling through Instagram
deciding if this is something worth
liking or not so there's there's
computing power in the human collective
consciousness that's being I think
wasted like do we like does Instagram
need to know that a celebrity looks good
heart okay this this girl in a bikini
looks good yeah it's like we're we're
using computing cycles right now we're
sad you uselessly yeah yeah maybe with
low utility yeah yeah okay so wearing a
one of the neuromodulation caps yeah
could rocket me into creative flow
states rather than be manipulated or
deceived by things that are distracting
me right or I could build up my own reap
a turning mechanism so here's the thing
it's like okay so I think here's what
we're getting at it's that it's that we
can take time to repattern our own
behaviors towards a nature and towards
their own self-actualization collective
actualization but is that actually going
to come fast enough to avoid some of the
civilizational collapse issues we have
because we can augment ourselves with
this to repattern those behaviors
quicker to avoid the civilizational
collapse and to wreak and to connect
faster to what provides us with with
life our nature as well as some of the
creativity okay alright I want to hit
mimetic were fat we're warfare with you
too on the way out because I think you
you know you and I both are carry this
mentality of like the age of the gene
seems to be in a sense taking a backseat
to the age of the meme like you can
disseminate memes and impact a billion
people but if you birth a child into the
world your time investments in one child
so what are your thoughts on the mimetic
warfare age yeah so it's it's a it's a
weird thing of how I actually learned
about any of this stuff it was just by
total chance I
learning how to run Facebook ads and I
was it was pretty much 2016-2017 and I
heard about how potentially powerful
Facebook ads could be and I went to cut
I wanted to kind of know if that was
true or not so I started looking into
like what does it take to take a meme
some kind of a symbolism some kind of a
message and rapidly propagate it through
social media if you have you know money
behind it and so I looked into I had a
really research like what is what our
memes what is mimetics and so I got a
really crash course through for about 18
months learning how to do Facebook ads
and doing some some better understanding
of how people are influenced through
social media and you know it really does
you know does relate back to my work in
neuromodulation which is you know we're
using a technology to stimulate the
brain Instagram and Facebook are
stimulating people's brains yeah you
know if you can't make that connection
it's it's there so I'm always thinking
about what are the implications of you
know this is this is a small technology
that's gonna be in the hands of a very
few researchers over the next few years
but what if this gets mainstream like
what is the what are the implications
and we already have an example which is
social media
it's a machine learning driving a system
where you have an input you have an
audience you put it to their eyes they
give feedback that you collect data on
that the machine makes some adjustments
and then it tries another round of
stimulation yeah so it's mass its
stimulation of the global brain yeah
through through your phone yeah so you
know these are this is just the thing I
think about whether it's on a individual
level
in the brain or if it's on a massive
scale and so what I found was that you
know through social media it did seem to
we talked about this earlier which is
that it did seem to be easier to create
discord and disconnection with people
through these ads if you're trying to
you know it's a lot easier to do that
than to create some kind of
action it takes a lot more work to
connect people than to just be you know
just throw a bunch of garbage it's a lot
harder to make newsfeed and nuanced
multi variability within news feeds and
empathy and love and that is to make
things that's a biased people into
tribes and yeah and a fear response fear
response and orphans versus versus like
love and compassion and yeah unity yeah
yeah but then the parallax is also
important because then you have actually
like ideas that can like build on top of
each other at times versus just yeah
this is kind of another one of the
debates between like the like what US
and China is kind of like moving forward
with yeah yeah it I want also like it
like like we're like regarding
influencing the global brain I feel as
though we can do it on a on a
neuromodulation using neuro Technology
basis these thinking caps this type of
stuff but when you explain it in terms
of just like being influenced by even
like a news feed or video or these types
of things I think that that deploys to 2
billion people like that yeah I think
that's much more relatable I think also
for people that like this is very
important that we have figure out how to
what is the most optimal way to deploy
these mimetics through the news feeds in
order for us to maximize our prosperity
and not our disconnection yeah that's a
definitely and you know it's the nature
of the viral meme is it's it's things
that it's really this whole sympathetic
nervous chain is you know it's it's not
a coincidence where I'm learning about
how people are affected by something
they see how they the people are
viscerally affected by things they see
on the internet they feel it like as if
it's a real threat to their being and in
some cases you know on a global
political level there are threats but
some people can take any meme is
very real threat like a saber-toothed
tiger is coming out of your laptop yeah
correct
so it's a lot easier to get control over
somebody's mind if you're using fear on
these platforms yeah it's almost it's a
child child's play to create love and
compassion beams yeah those don't those
don't perform use fear based yeah means
that's the thing is that we got to kick
the kick out the the fear yeah because
they perform better right yeah yeah yeah
we need the other ones they'll never
take me alive rom be taking you so much
yeah they get it okay let's let's do a
couple quick questions on the way out um
what do you think happens before birth
and after death hmm
before birth and after death I mean
besides the obvious answer you know
reproduction wise um I don't know I the
the non like materialist answer would be
something about we are if we're in a
simulation or if we're in a hologram
which I think about that kind of stuff a
little bit if we're in some kind of a
pre simulation then I think that there
could be these ideas of archetypes of
people that were kind of built into a
some some original template that were
born from because I've had times where
I've seen people and I've been like you
remind me so much of somebody that else
that I've met this happened multiple
totally because I met so many people
through this work and I'm like wow it's
like I'm talking to the same person you
know you have the same interests you
have the same look there's just some
part of me that can't ignore that
reality yeah so there's some things they
got loaded from the safe yeah and
there's generally so much variability in
the species and people that you don't
not normally detect it unless you're
really careful to look where and there
you've met a lot of people yeah most
people don't meet enough people to
detect that yeah generally speaking but
yeah if you do get out there enough you
go to have conferences you're out there
enough you start to notice these things
so I've kind of seen that and that
make me wonder about what's going on
before what's the loading bay look like
kind of the loading bay yeah the loading
bay our consciousness before we get
jettisoned out into the into the
material world for us yes
the hologram simulation and then in
terms of when we die
I mean I've this that's such a loaded
question I I mean I don't know probably
it's really hard to say you know I've
personally lost people to suicide my
sister for instance and I've thought
about that for sure because I don't
really know I wish I know part of me
wants to know but um you know I think
that what was the was that with her what
was it she she was prescribed
antidepressants for about three months
and she had attempted suicide before in
her life but never success successfully
but I think that antidepressants made
her really decide to to go for it and
she she hung herself in Portland Oregon
in 2014 so it really sucked and I
remember I actually was trying to try to
find answers and trying to figure out
what happens and I did find some
research on that you know the brain
still operates minutes fifteen minutes
or longer hours after you die and
there's some some idea that your rien
coding your life experience back into
the eight of the simulation like it so
it's like a it's like a lived experience
and you you like teach a lesson in some
way so that's that's my theory on what
happens when we die
but I don't think we're I don't know if
right entirely coherent but we get kind
of like resettle back into the end of
the hologram in some way so we do kind
of still have a lingering effect
this seems like it also kind of
potentially launched you into wanting to
understand like what was going on in her
brain that made her like decide to do
yeah death which is why you're in this
field now yeah and now we're with people
who are depressed a lot so I I really
want to help yeah yeah yeah I'm
surprised that you didn't mention that
at the beginning part of your life that
part of your yeah yes I'm for
endeavoring into to where you're at now
yeah it was a big I mean I started I
actually did get into it before and it
happened yeah but then that happened
during the time the launch of my company
and so just became more clear than ever
that that there's the time that's now to
do this because I can't wait
I can't yeah yeah yeah what's her name
Carrie Carrie yeah
Carrie yeah as long as we keep her alive
in our heart and mention her name
yep Carrie Cooley Carrie Cooley yeah
yeah my older sister she was 30 when it
happened I'm 30 now some of the same age
as my sister just been a interesting
thing this year in particular but yeah
you know was it just her and you as
siblings mm-hmm yeah yeah yeah her her
and me my and her mom and mom my mom
mostly
yeah so
it's never easy losing someone
definitely opens up a lot of questions
about what happened yeah but it also
opens up our imagination to the
possibilities of you know who we are and
you asking these questions Alan what
were you before birth where do you go
when you die and then we're talking
about carry so it does also open our
imagination for wonderful possibilities
beyond this body that holds us
temporarily yes like yeah yeah yeah
exactly and just as fast as it comes it
can go and so you know I think you got
to make the most out of what you got
yeah whatever you have you got to make
the most of your time here yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's right that's right
that's right
so do amazing stuff yeah yeah yeah you
know do you think that we're in a
simulation mmm yes and no so I thought
about this we are in a simulation for
sure and the simulation is I'm
simulating you in my head right now
you're simulating me in your head and
the brain is a very low information
holding cavity there's so much more
information in this room then that that
your brain is not detecting so you'll
find that I feel like you know you
experience like psychedelics you see way
more of an inflow of information that
you didn't realize us there so yes
there's a simulation because there's a
lack of information so you have to
simulate things that's why optical
illusions work so well so there's that
level of simulation and then in terms of
if we are in it like a silicone
simulation or something it's either it's
either that or we're in some kind of a
hologram like collected light photons
that are densely packed inside of a
black hole meaning that our our matter
was already compacted into a black hole
already and we're just super dense
photons floating around influencing each
other thinking that we're conscious
imagining all this
that's the other option or we're just
actually alive and we're really this is
all real and we're the first ones and we
will at some point simulate some people
and then what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world hmm
most beautiful thing in the world uh I
don't know I think like new generations
of children you know the people who
aren't so cynical that has a fresh
perspective people have hope yeah yeah
yeah it's beautiful yeah Stanley thank
you so much thank you so much man thank
you
yeah really awesome man thank you thank
you thank you thanks everyone for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode do check out the links as
well to certain cool calm the website as
well as the Facebook group go and check
that out go and join the group and join
the conversation worldwide with your
friends your family coworkers people
online on social media about influencing
the global brain through things as
simple as memes all the way to things
like neuromodulation so get talking
about that more huge shout out to Ron
Vargas for producing and directing
thank you very much Ronny and yes thank
you yeah and also support the artists on
traverse the organizations around the
world that you believe in support
simulation our links are below help us
grow as well and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world thank you so much for tuning in
and we will see you soon
[Music]
[Music]